baby emmanuel is just three weeks old
born in moria when the camp started
burning her parents ran for the life
now they are sleeping on the roadside
i am so disappointed because the
european union could have helped us
after all this time
it's been four days no one is taking
care of us
what are they thinking how can they
abandon us the european union too i
don't know what they are doing
the family fled the democratic republic
of congo others came from afghanistan or
syria
now they're all stranded here katrin
guring eckhart leader of the greens in
the german parliament
is one of the few politicians who visit
the island
this is the last chance to say we
urgently need to change our asylum
policy it's all about
law and humanity humanity and law both
it's the only way we can really live up
to our european values
a few kilometers away tents are being
set up at an old shooting range
but refugees gathered here tell us they
don't want another camp like
morya we need the government to support
us to be evacuation maybe under other
country you know
maybe other country maybe in germany
france
belgium sweden norway no way that is
going to be good idea
but decided to be the intent maybe two
days ago we're going to see again
in the fire and that's how many here
feel
their frustration leads to hours long
protests
[Music]
they chant freedom and are not afraid to
confront the greek riot police
here is the the fourth situation
for the refugee we don't have toilets we
don't have water we don't have anything
and we need your freedom freedom
please help us people here are getting
more and more impatient they are
marching back and forth to demonstrate
their anger they tell us we don't want
to stay here greece cannot take care of
us
maurya was held we want to leave this
island
this time everything remains peaceful
but the longer the standoff continues
the bigger the risk that the situation
could get out of hand
and let's bring in alexander fonnaman
who filed that report she's standing by
near the site of the moria refugee camp
on lesbos hello to you alexandra so
we've heard it's already been nearly
four days since the fire
destroyed the camp describe the
situation there now
so at the moment it's quite quiet here
compared to yesterday
people are getting ready for what is
going to be another hot day here
they are cleaning their make shift tents
and
actually i was struck by by that that
they were able to put them
up so quickly while we are still waiting
for the greek government
to live up to its promise to provide
housing for
their refugees but of course the
conditions here
are grim sanitary conditions there's
only little running water
no toilets and people really think that
they have been
abandoned by by the european union and
they
are getting uh increasingly frustrated
as we saw in the report we saw protests
yesterday and of course
i can assume that we are going uh to see
them protesting
today again now alexandra what
have you been hearing from the local
authorities what is their plan
to provide food and shelter to the
refugees how are they going to do all of
that
well what we saw here on the ground were
mainly ngos
distributing food and water but
many refugees told us that they don't
have enough food that they are hungry
that they don't have enough water
i really myself didn't see any local
authorities here on the ground
although we know that they're also
distributing food
they started as we saw in the report
setting up those
tents a few kilometers away from from
here
uh the greek government has sent three
ships
to provide housing to to the people but
it's gonna take a while and and many of
the refugees here told us that they just
don't
want to stay here they want to move on
they want to leave the island
because they don't believe that the
greek authorities can really take care
of that
and if you are here on the ground you
see that that's really the case
well what about the greek local
residents i mean the the residents of
lesbos themselves how are they reacting
to what's going on
well they're very upset and angry they
say
they don't want another camp to be built
here they say they have been facing the
situation for five years now when
someone else
needs to bear this burden a burden we
ran actually yesterday into a local
blockade everything was
peaceful we could pass through this
blockade but
that can change any day if the
authorities here will uh
push through with their plan to to to
build another camp in moya
dw's alexander phenomenon on the greek
island of lesbos thank you so much for
your reporting
you